MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Uah!
Ein Lauf, ein Gang
in etwas Unbekanntes.
Hu!
Das hatten wir lange nicht mehr.
Grüezi, wir sind Jonny ...
... und Manu
vom Cabaret DivertiMento.
Nein, nein, nein!
Spinnt ihr eigentlich?
Seit zwei Wochen
wandern wir schon zusammen.
Das Ziel der Reise ist, dass wir
uns wieder etwas näher kommen.
Damit die Freundschaft
wieder menschlicher
und weniger beruflich wird.
150 km durch Schottland -
wir kämpfen.
Ich bin echt erledigt.
Heute war die Etappe sehr lang.
Auch in der dritten Folge
haben wir Spezielles erlebt.
Das uns ziemlich
an den Anschlag brachte.
Ich will nicht mehr.
Aber genau deswegen
ist diese Reise so einzigartig.
Ich weiss, dass ich meinen Enkeln
noch davon erzählen werde.
Das ist "SRF bi de Lüt -
Durch dick ...
... und dünn."
Seit fast zwei Wochen
sind wir in Schottland unterwegs,
aber dieser Tag ist speziell.
Erstens war das Wetter wunderschön
und zweitens,
das ist fast noch wichtiger,
es war der 1. November, der Geburts-
tag meines Bühnenpartners Manu.
Er hat für einmal
nicht das Kalb gemacht.
Wir waren nämlich ziemlich müde.
Burki, da hast du deine Highlands!
Ja, da kommen sie.
- An deinem Geburtstag.
An diesem Tag waren wir
tatsächlich ziemlich erledigt.
Am Abend zuvor haben wir
meinen Geburtstag gefeiert,
als ob es keinen Morgen gäbe.
# Happy Birthday, dear Manu!
Ich dachte, weil du Geburtstag hast.
Mein Geburtstagsessen.
Was ich nicht wusste: In diesem Zug,
direkt neben dem Wanderweg,
sitzt meine Frau Michele.
Ja, Manu, es war schwierig,
dass du nichts gemerkt hast.
Schon seit Tagen
war ich am Koordinieren,
damit Michele
zu deinem Geburtstag hierherkommt.
Das ist Crianlarich.
Hierher habe ich Michele als
Geburtstagsüberraschung gelotst.
Hi guys!
Please wait to be seated.
- Wollt ihr uns in der Ecke haben?
Was macht ihr eigentlich?
Ich habe wirklich nichts verstanden.
Eine Aufregung
wegen meinem Geburtstag!
Und ich wollte
doch nur unter die Dusche.
Bevor ich
zu meinem kleinen Geschenk komme,
habe ich hier einen Film von deiner
Frau, den sie uns mitgegeben hat.
* Unverständliche
Kinderglückwünsche *
Habt es gut miteinander!
Viele Grüsse an Jonny und die Crew.
Geniesse es! Ich liebe dich.
Tschau, Papi!
Vielen Dank ...
... für die Präsentation.
Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Ich habe nicht gedacht,
dass nach gestern Nacht
noch einmal etwas kommt.
Das war von deiner Frau. Ich habe
auch etwas Kleines für dich gemacht.
# Happy Birthday to you.
Nein, nein, nein! Spinnt ihr?
Scheisse!
Hoi!
Ich gratuliere dir zum Geburtstag.
- Spinnt ihr eigentlich?
Du hast nichts gemerkt, oder?
Nein!
Komm schnell, ein Drückerchen!
Hey, nein, das ist jetzt gerade
ziemlich surreal.
Shit!
Was machst du
hier in diesen Crianlarich?
Ich bin für dich gekommen.
Das ist auf Jonnys Mist gewachsen.
Ich bin
mit dieser Situation überfordert.
Ich bin Röbi Koller
und fange sie etwas auf.
So geht es weiter:
Wir gehen zurück ins Studio.
Nein, wie kommst du hierher?
So schön.
Meine Frau steht hier!
Wahnsinn, eine solche Überraschung
habe ich echt noch nie erlebt.
Meine Frau
mitten in der schottischen Pampa.
Tausend Dank, Fischer.
Schon recht.
219 haben sie gesagt.
Ich komme.
Es ist 6 Uhr.
Ich sage noch Tschüss.
Sie geht zum Flughafen.
Hast du fertig gepackt?
- Ja.
Ist es noch etwas früh?
Ich liebe Kameralicht frühmorgens.
Halte mich auch!
Es war mega cool.
Passt auf!
Du bist zweieinhalb Tage unterwegs
für die 12 Std.
Danke, dass du mitgemacht hast.
Gutes Durchhalten.
- Vielen Dank.
Macht es gut
und saugt noch alles auf!
Behaltet die Nerven!
Das kommt ganz auf die Crew an.
Also, macht es gut.
Tschüss, viel Spass!
Gute Reise!
Jö!
- Gute Nacht.
Nein, in 20 Min.
treffen wir uns draussen.
Das war eine kurze Nacht,
nicht nur wegen meiner Frau.
An diesem Tag hatten wir 25 km vor
uns und sind darum richtig früh los.
Vor zwei Wochen haben wir unsere
Reise durch Schottland gestartet.
Angefangen hat sie in Glasgow.
Von dort führt der West Highland Way
150 km Richtung Norden
zu unserem Ziel Fort William.
Crianlarich, in dem wir übernachtet
haben, ist in der Hälfte des Weges.
Hu, Crianlarich! - Hierher komme ich
nicht unbedingt wieder.
Ja, ich habe es auch gesehen.
# Im Wald im schöne grüene Wald
han ich äs Plätzli, womer gfallt.
Von wem ist das?
# Ich ligge da im weiche Moos ...
Das habe ich
im Kindergarten gelernt.
So, Bürkeli!
- Hat es hier Holz?
Jetzt haben wir die Hälfte.
- Halb auf dem Weg.
Kannst du hier unser
Zielschnäppschen heraussuchen?
Das Problem ist,
wir haben die Hälfte des Weges ...
... und die Hälfte des Fläschchens.
... und schon
zwei Drittel der Zeit gebraucht.
Jetzt müssen wir Gas geben.
Es ist 7.15 Uhr und wir haben
noch kein Frühstück gehabt.
Oh, so schön!
Ab jetzt gibt es nichts mehr.
Super, einmal mehr
auf nüchternen Magen!
7.15 Uhr. Das haben wir schon
zum zweiten Mal zum Frühstück.
Hu!
Es wärmt. Da muss ich gleich
alles ausziehen.
* "I'm Gonna Be"
von The Proclaimers *
Wir waren sehr schnell unterwegs -
hätte uns nicht ständig
die Kameracrew ausgebremst.
(Kameramann) Ihr könnt weitergehen.
Ihr könnt weitergehen.
* "I'm Gonna Be"
von The Proclaimers *
* Quietschen *
Es muss quietschen.
Ein alter, überwachsener Friedhof.
Genau so habe ich mir
Schottland vorgestellt,
nur der Bodennebel fehlt.
Dort ist eine Kameracrew.
Überall hat es schöne Natur
und dann solches Zeugs dort oben.
Der Campingplatz von Strathfillan:
3 Std. hatten wir bis hierher -
und konnten endlich frühstücken.
Hier geht es dann bergauf -
Scheisse!
Drei, vier, fünf ...
- Geil!
... sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn.
Sind wir heute ... äh ...
... im Bitch of ...
Bitch of Orchy.
- Bitch of Orchy.
Dort sind wir heute.
Schön - Bitch of Orchy.
Und das Loch Trulla.
Das ist so geil.
Ich freue mich sehr,
dass ich so fit bin.
Klar, es kann noch die eine
oder andere Steigung kommen.
Es ist einfach schön,
die Zeit zum Wandern zu haben.
Ich merke,
dass mir das sehr gut tut.
V.a., dass ...
Das haben wir vorhin besprochen.
Der Druck, den man daheim hat ...
Jede Stunde schaut man doch nach,
ob man eine Mail bekommen hat.
Das ist hier anders.
Hier schaut man nicht nach und
Facebook und alles ist weit weg.
Das tut gut.
- Ja. Wirklich.
Und genau deshalb
sind wir hierher gekommen.
Einfach wieder einmal Zeit haben
für uns und unsere Freundschaft.
Wegen unserer Freundschaft:
Die letzten zwei Wochen hatten wir
täglich einen kleinen Wettkampf,
wer Tageschef ist und sagt,
wo's lang geht.
Aber nach dieser langen Zeit unter-
wegs waren wir nicht mehr sicher,
ob das eine gute Idee war.
Es hat deswegen
ab und zu Streit gegeben.
Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch
ans Tontaubenschiessen
in der letzten Sendung.
Der Tageschef hat quasi die Voll-
macht über gewisse Entscheidungen:
wo man schläft, wann man wo
eine Essenspause macht ...
... oder übernachten.
Nach einer Woche haben wir entschie-
den, das wir das weiterziehen.
Man spürt die Begeisterung
bei meinem heissgeliebten,
38-jährigen Freund.
Die Begeisterung
war von Anfang an brodelnd.
Komm, wir gehen weiter
und überlegen!
Ja, man merkt,
ich war nicht begeistert.
Diese Tageschef-Geschichte
hat uns mehr auseinander
statt zusammen gebracht.
Das sieht man hier gut.
Darum hat jeder für sich
darüber sinniert
und wir haben gemeinsam
eine Entscheidung gefällt.
Wir lassen
das Sideprojekt Tageschef sterben.
Das Chef sein, das Militärische,
das Hierarchische ...
In unserer Zusammenarbeit
hat das keinen Platz.
Auch wir als Personen ... Ich hatte
im Militär sehr Mühe damit.
Manu auch. Das war auch eine
Auseinanderersetzung als Lehrer.
Ich habe nicht gerne gesagt: "So und
so geht es." Das kann ich nicht.
Ich weiss, dass das
den anderen nicht passt.
Wir sind eher mehr
die Spürst-du-mich-Fraktion,
die alles ausdiskutiert
bis es für alle stimmt.
Ja, definitiv.
Geht es dir auch so?
Das konnte man schon
in jenen Interviews lesen,
auch Leute, die um mich herum leben,
wissen: Ich bin ein Harmonie-Freak.
D.h. nicht, dass ich mich
vor allen Spannungen drücke.
Denen stelle ich mich schon,
aber nicht gerne.
Und es ist mir auch klar ...
# Schubabaluba bow.
Tageschef!
Immer muss ich warten.
Er hat langsam Entzugserscheinungen
nach der Zivilisation.
Ich bin dafür, dass man
den Tageschef wieder einführt.
Das ist einfach kein ...
Er kann kein Tempo annehmen.
Das ist richtig service public,
dafür bezahlen die Leute.
Wir probieren aus, wie Nacktwandern
im hohen Norden sich anfühlt.
Nacktwandern hat mich
schon immer interessiert.
2. November, alles schneidet ein
und es ist arschkalt - 4 °C.
Wie viel Grad?
- Vier oder so ähnlich.
Wenn ich auf meinen Thermometer hin-
unterschaue, haben wir unter Null.
Komm, Burki!
- Ja, ja, komm!
Also das Fazit war klar:
Nacktwandern im Norden - no way!
* Dynamische Musik *
Sieht das geil aus!
Das Highlight des Tages:
Das Team hat für alle Curry gekocht.
Ich sage nie mehr
etwas gegen die Crew.
* "An Roghain Dain Do Eimhir Xxii"
von Julie Fowlis *
* Sanfte Klänge
mit sphärischem Gesang *
Ah, war das Curry gut! So bin ich
richtig motiviert weitergegangen,
auch wenn wir noch
ein paar Kilometer vor uns hatten
und meine Blasen schmerzten.
Und auch sonst war
irgendetwas im Kommen:
ein komischer Kopf, wie ein leichtes
Fieber hat es sich angefühlt.
* Sanfte Klänge
mit sphärischem Gesang *
Der Weg war gut
und das Panorama genau so, wie ich
mir das immer vorgestellt habe.
Weite Landschaft, karg,
kein Mensch und nur Schafe.
Wir sind gelaufen und gelaufen.
Und gefühlt keinen Meter
vorwärtsgekommen.
Irgendwie hat immer
alles gleich ausgesehen.
* Sanfte Klänge
mit sphärischem Gesang *
Bitch of Orchy.
- Bridge, Jonny, brigde.
Brigde of Orchy war unser Tagesziel.
Aber diese Brücke
war es leider noch nicht.
Nach 8 Std. wandern kamen wir end-
lich in diesem Brigde of Orchy an.
Ein Miniort an der Hauptstrasse.
Hier haben wir
ein Zimmer reserviert.
Schon hier riecht es
nach schottischem Hotel.
Das ist mir wieder ein Castle!
Hui, jetzt spüre ich meine Beine.
- Ich auch.
Der rechte Fuss ...
Du, das ist ein 4-Stern ...
Hör auf!
- Ein 4-Stern, schottisches 4-Stern.
Weit war es.
Das sagt mir: 25,5 km - heute.
Darauf habe ich mich
richtig gefreut.
Ein Kinoabend mit "Braveheat",
dem schottischen Heldenepos
mit Mel Gibson in der Hauptrolle.
Im Zusammenhang mit Schottland
bringe ich schnell
den Film "Braveheart".
Er ist einer meiner Lieblingsfilme.
Ich habe ein kleines Döschen
blaue Gesichtsfarbe mitgenommen.
Ich dachte, es wäre cool auf unserer
Reise so etwas nachzustellen.
Er ist mein Heer.
Ach, Burki, du hast immer Ideen.
Goodbye Brigde of Orchy.
Leider, leider,
es war ein Hammer-Hotel.
Burkhard-Fischer -
das erste Mal leicht angeschlagen.
Leicht angeschlagen.
Das rote Männchen neben mir
hat leichtes Fieber,
einen blöden Kopf
und mir knackt die linke Hüfte.
Ich wurde 38, das hat sich
sofort niedergeschlagen.
Alles wurde anders.
Wir schaffen das,
aber die letzten drei, vier Tage
müssen wir noch etwas kämpfen.
Jetzt müssen wir
etwas sorgfältiger sein.
Die letzten zwei Tage
sind wir gerannt.
Und das bergerprobte Team
ist total begeistert,
wie wir trainiert und schnell sind.
Wir müssen hier hinauf.
Jetzt haben wir sie beeindruckt.
Von jetzt an können wir normal sein
und ganz langsam hier hinaufgehen.
* "I'm Gonna Be" von George MacKay &
Antonia Thomas & Pete. *
* Sanfte Musik *
An diesem Tag
musste ich wirklich etwas kämpfen.
Ich muss heute etwas sorgfältiger
sein. Ich bin etwas angeschlagen.
Das ist der einzige Hügel.
Ich muss schauen, dass ich
nicht schon am Anschlag bin.
Ich habe heute Nacht
extrem geschwitzt.
Ich glaube,
Fieber habe ich nicht mehr.
Schluckweh habe ich noch.
* Sanfte Musik *
Auf dem Hügel haben wir
ein deutsches Paar getroffen,
das auch auf dem Weg
nach Fort William unterwegs war.
Unser Plan für diesen Tag war,
mit einem Jäger durch das Moor
und Wild beobachten.
Wofür braucht es einen Jäger?
Voila, hier sind sie.
Schau, jetzt pfeift er sie!
Okay, wir haben bald herausgefunden,
dass das halb zahme Tiere sind,
die vom Hotelier gefüttert werden.
* Sanfte Klänge
mit sphärischem Gesang *
Bei diesem Haus haben wir uns
mit dem Jäger verabredet.
Von einem Jäger hat man ein
klares Bild. - Die reden wenig.
Sie sind still, damit sie
die Rehe nicht aufscheuchen.
(Flüstert) Ganz leise.
- (Flüstert) Ganz leise.
Ja, das ist er.
- Schau dir dieses Gefährt an!
Nice to meet you!
- Callum.
Das ist das Moormobil
vom Jägermeister Callum Proctor.
...your managment in this aera?
How big is the area?
35'000 ha.
Sorry?
What's our plan?
Would you like to take
a ride in this?
That would be great.
Callum ist Wildhüter und sein Revier
ist 35'000 ha gross.
Boah, das ist grösser als der ganze
Kanton Zug, in dem ich wohne.
Callum hat uns
ins Rannoch Moor mitgenommen.
Dieses Moor wurde nie kultiviert,
darum soll es hier Natur pur sein
mit vielen Tieren.
Ich hätte vorher
besser noch gepisst.
Jetzt ist es zu spät.
Also ich muss sagen, mir hat
diese Fahrt sehr gut gefallen.
Wir können mit der Fahrt
nicht viele Kilometer aufholen.
Es ist cool. Wir sind irgendwo,
wo nie ein Mensch hinkommt.
Da kommt die Crew
durch den Nebel hinauf.
Sie müssen durch den Morast laufen.
Das ist anstrengend.
Callum fährt hier
auf einer alten Militärstrasse.
Wobei diese Strasse nicht wirklich
als solche erkennbar ist.
The bridge is missing here,
so we're just gonna cross
slightly higher up.
Okay. - You'll have to get out.
It's a bit rocky.
Callum meinte,
dass hier die Brücke fehle
und es etwas gefährlich sein könnte.
Darum musste ich aussteigen.
Es war alles halb so wild.
Apropos Wild: Ausser Callums Hund
haben wir in diesem Nebel
kein einziges Tier gesehen.
Naja, egal. Wir haben unsere Rehe
beim Hotel gesehen.
Thank you very, very much.
Nice to meet you.
Prince of Scotland!
Bye!
Wir alle wussten nicht, was auf uns
zukommt, was er mit uns macht.
Lustig fand ich, dass er immer
von einem Armeeweg sprach.
Es war einfach ein verdammter Sumpf.
Wir sind wirklich auf einer
alten Militärstrasse gefahren.
Aber er musste sie
ab und zu selber suchen.
Wahrscheinlich kamen hier einmal
zwölf Kreuzritter durch.
Aber umso abenteuerlicher ...
Am Schluss
hatten wir noch das Gefühl,
das Gefährt kippe nach hinten.
Wir mussten abspringen.
Es war super.
Ich habe solche Sachen sehr gerne.
Kopfsteinpflaster!
- Ja, du ...
* Sphärische Musik *
Nach ein paar Kilometer kamen wir
zum höchsten Punkt des Moors.
Traumhaft hier oben - diese Ruhe.
* Erhabene Musik *
Nach diesem magischen Moment
war es dann eine harte Landung
in der Realität unten im Nebelmeer.
Das ist nicht
ein sehr romantisches Plätzchen.
Ein schöner Parkplatz
ist auch etwas Schönes.
Das sind die Unterkünfte
von Glencoe, einem Skigebiet.
Darum der grosse Parkplatz.
* Jonny lacht. *
- Ist es ...
Vier.
Aber auf den kleinen
kann man nicht schlafen.
So, jetzt, was machen wir?
Die Frage ist,
ob das Restaurant offen ist.
Gehen wir nachsehen!
Hast du schon gefragt?
Es ist ein gemütliches Restaurant,
aber sie schliessen gleich.
Das Restaurant?
Ja, dann ist klar ...
Von mir aus können wir weitergehen.
Ja, das muss ich ... jaja.
30 Min.
- 30 Min.
* "I'm Gonna Be"
von The Proclaimers *
Es wurde sehr spät, bis wir
in diesem Hotel angekommen sind.
Und gefühlte 5 Min. später
standen wir schon wieder
in der schottischen Morgenkälte.
Heute Morgen können wir von hier
oben durch -
zuerst der Strasse nach.
Eine sehr schöne Strecke -
man läuft direkt neben der Autobahn.
Good morning.
- Nice.
It's a bit cold.
You slept in here?
- Yeah.
Wow. It wasn't too cold?
This is the second van.
The last one lasted ten years,
I've had this two years,
so it's twelve years in these.
Dieser Mann heisst Steve. Er lebt
schon seit zwölf Jahren in Autos.
Er ist immer unterwegs.
In einem Auto leben -
boah, das wäre gar nichts für mich.
Bye!
- Bye! - Bye!
Mega interessant.
- Cool!
Hu, aber hart to understand.
- Ja, schwierig zu verstehen.
Der Weg ging zwar
entlang der Hauptstrasse,
war aber irgendwie doch noch schön.
* Erhabene Musik *
The Devil's Staircase -
des Teufels Treppe.
Das war unser Weg.
Wir befinden uns
auf der Devil's Staircase,
eine steile, höllisch
schweisstreibende Passage
auf eine Passhöhe hinauf.
Da wollen wir doch
auf den richtigen Soundtrack hoffen.
Ja, sehr passend Burki,
diese Teufelsmusik.
* Heavy Metal *
Jetzt kam etwas Ehrgeiz auf.
Ich habe Freude.
Ich bin mega entspannt.
Jetzt muss ich nur darauf achten,
dass ich ruhig atme,
damit ich nachher
total entspannt bin.
Naja, total entspannt
sieht etwas anders aus.
Aber immerhin,
ich war der erste, der oben war.
Ich atme ganz normal.
Das ist der höchste Punkt
unserer Wanderung.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Es war eigentlich easy,
es sind nur 300 Höhenmeter.
Es war am Schluss doch noch recht
steil. Ich bin froh um eine Pause.
Ich bin William Wallace
und ich kämpfe
für die Freiheit von Schottland!
Schaut euch
die Bastarde von Engländern an!
Ich habe kalte Hände.
Wir lassen sie uns nicht nehmen,
unsere Ländereien, unsere Frauen,
unsere Playstation,
unsere Rasenmäher!
Du bist ja gar nicht geschminkt.
Du brauchst eine Kriegsbemalung.
- Ich habe einfach kalte Hände.
Ist es unheimlich?
- Mega.
Gehen wir in den Krieg!
- Ja.
Uah!
Yeah!
* Manu schreit. *
- Manu?
* Manu schreit wieder. *
Scheisse!
Ja, Freiheit!
Gut, dann mache ich den Ton.
* "I'm On My Way"
von The Proclaimers *
* Lockere Musik *
Ich finde den Film
auch absolut den Knaller.
Ich wäre nicht
auf die Idee gekommen,
ihn während des Wanderns
nachzuspielen.
Und ihn bei 3 °C und 140 Knoten Wind
die Szene 1 1/2 Std. nachzuspielen.
Aber es war sehr lustig.
So sind wir. Logisch,
manchmal habe ich eine Idee,
manchmal hat auch
der andere eine Idee.
Und einer ist nicht gerade Fan
und begeistert davon.
Aber ich finde es cool,
dass wir beide dem anderen
den Gefallen machen.
Es hat sich fast immer gelohnt.
Unserem Tontechniker geht es
natürlich gut. Er steht hier.
Aber mir ist es bald
nicht mehr so gut gegangen.
Der Weg
wollte und wollte nicht enden.
Ich war etwas angepisst und
habe mich mit dem Team angelegt.
Verfluchte Schweinekarte!
Scheisse! Wir wollten 11 km machen
und jetzt sind wir bei km 18.
Das ist für den Kopf nicht gut.
Diese Stimmung spürt nun Hänsu.
Tut mir leid,
aber das pisst mich an.
Ich habe die Höhenlinie gesehen,
aber es geht ja um den Weg.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal.
Es ist schon zweimal passiert.
Wir sagten, es sei sehr lange.
Der letzte Kilometer
und wir sputen uns ...
Jetzt sind wir hier
hinunter gerannt,
und sind seit 1 1/2 Std. unterwegs.
Normalerweise
machen wir 2,5 km in 30 Min.
Scheisskarte, Scheissland,
Scheisskaff da unten!
Abstellen, fortwerfen, zertrampeln!
Der Mist ist: Man kann uns
mit unserer Gesichtsbemalung
im Moment nicht ernst nehmen.
Ja, ja, ich weiss, das war etwas
peinlich als ehemaliger Lehrer.
Unterdessen weiss ich,
dass man die Höhenlinie
auf der Karte mit einbeziehen muss.
Wir haben es doch noch
nach Kinlochleven geschafft.
Ich bin das erste Mal
etwas erledigt.
Ich bin immer noch geschminkt.
Ich bin echt erledigt.
Heute war die Etappe sehr weit.
Und äh ...
Ich habe es unterschätzt.
Das ist Kacke!
Ich bin etwas steil hineingegangen.
Jetzt sind wir
nur noch zwei Tage unterwegs,
aber momentan
habe ich es nicht im Griff,
dass ich es easy nehmen könnte.
Es ist so ... ah ...
Hoffentlich geht das noch.
* "A Ghaoil, Leig Dhachaigh
Gum Mh ..." von Julie Fowlis *
* Sphärischer Gesang *
Am zweitletzen Wandertag
sind wir im Hochtal von Lairigmor,
auf Deutsch: Der grosse Pass.
Dieses Tal ist seit den 50er-Jahren
des letzten Jahrhunderts unbewohnt.
Wir waren einmal mehr
mutterseelenallein.
Mein grösstes Problem an diesem Tag:
Kein Speicherplatz mehr für Fotos.
Und auch sonst war irgendwie
keine Kapazität mehr vorhanden.
* Sphärischer Gesang *
Wir sind ein Stück weit froh,
haben wir es bald geschafft.
Ein Stück weit?
- Ein Stück weit.
Hier gemütlich vor dem Chalet Edel-
weiss zu sitzen, finde ich schön.
Wieder einmal ein gesundes Picknick.
Es ist jetzt dann gut,
haben wir es geschafft.
Seit gestern Abend ist die Luft
etwas draussen, auch körperlich.
Heute bin ich am Kämpfen,
obwohl es ein easy day ist.
Ich freue mich auf zu Hause.
Ich mochte eigentlich nicht mehr
und Manu hatte schon wieder
grossartige Pläne.
Ich hatte die Idee,
eine Schwitzhütte zu bauen.
Ich habe noch nie
eine selber gebaut.
Es ist ein cooles Erlebnis. Man gibt
3 Std. lang heisse Steine ins Feuer.
Mal schauen.
- Ja, mach du das.
Es muss dann schon klappen.
Jeden Tag etwas anderes: Entweder
male ich mir das Gesicht an
und springe über die Berge.
Und am nächsten Tag muss ich
splitternackt in einem Zelt sitzen,
obwohl ich den ganzen Tag
geschwitzt habe.
Gut, ich musste
splitternackt wandern.
Das war ja nicht mein Wunsch,
etwas schon.
# Lueget, vo Berg und Tal
# flieht scho de Sunnestrahl.
# Lueget vo Aue und Matte
# wachse die dunkele Schatte.
# D'Sunn uf de Berge no stoht.
# O, wie sind d'Gletscher so rot.
Ich danke dir vielmals.
Ich freue mich,
dass ich das noch erleben durfte.
Ich musste etwas schmunzeln.
Manu wollte unterwegs plötzlich
nichts mehr
von seiner Schwitzhütte wissen.
Er hatte Angst,
dass wir kein Holz finden.
Und dann das:
hektarenweise kaputter Wald.
Brennholz a discretion.
Dort unter den Bäumen
kann man ein Zelt stellen.
Und auf der Anhöhe
auch noch einmal eines.
Ich will nicht mehr.
Ich habe keine Lust mehr.
Alles gut, Jonny?
- Ja, super.
Vielleicht wird es doch noch was
mit dieser Schwitzhütte.
Das Feuer haben wir.
Jetzt machen wir hot stone.
Legt man die so rein?
- Ja.
Sprengt es sie nicht?
- Doch, das kann passieren.
Kannst du mir sicherheitsmässig
eine blaue Brille anmalen?
So geil!
Du bist ein dummer Kerl!
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin froh, denn ich habe seit
fünf Tagen dieselben Unterhosen an.
Frisch gesponserte Unterhosen
von unserem Team.
Los geht es
mit dem Abenteuer Schwitzhütte!
Wenn das wie ein Dampfbad ist,
ist das super für die Haut.
Ich habe so viele Pickel bekommen.
Erstickst du? - Der Rauch
brennt extrem in den Augen.
Irgendetwas war nicht gut.
Wir sind fast erstickt.
Ich habe ihn ja gerne
für solche Sachen, immer gute Ideen.
Der Rauch im Zelt war richtig giftig
und buchstäblich atemberaubend.
Kommst du?
Das war deine Idee.
- Ja, aber so ...
3 1/2 Std. haben wir
den Scheiss aufgebaut.
Jetzt sitzen wir 10 Min. drin,
und wenn wir nachher tot sind.
Ich glaube, auf die Dauer
ist das gesundheitsschädigend.
Ich würde in 5 Min.
noch etwas Wasser dazugeben.
Aber nur noch einmal.
* Dynamische Musik *
Aua!
Jetzt hält man es langsam aus.
Es hat immer noch einen Erdgeruch,
den wir einatmen.
Aber es ist nicht mehr so schlimm.
Am Schluss
war es wirklich zum Aushalten.
Es war nicht schlecht.
Ich will es zu Hause
noch einmal versuchen.
Ich nehme an,
es ist die verbrannte Erde,
die einen ekligen Geschmack
verbreitet hat.
Im Nachhinein
habe ich mir sagen lassen,
dass man ein Kiesbeet unter
die heissen Steine legen sollte.
Konntest du schlafen?
- Nein!
Gleich schlecht wie die erste Nacht,
aber heute ist es mir egal.
Auf nach Fort William!
Der letzte Tag unterwegs -
ich verstehe es noch nicht ganz.
Zuerst müssen wir uns
jetzt aufraffen.
Nach, einmal mehr,
nach einer miserablen Nacht
bin ich trotzdem gut gelaunt,
weil es jetzt wirklich
dem Ende entgegengeht.
Jetzt sind wir genug gewandert.
* "I'm Gonna Be" von George MacKay &
Antonia Thomas & Pete. *
* Sanfte Musik *
Und das ist es endlich:
Fort William, unser grosses Ziel
von dieser Reise.
Die ersten 3 km
haben wir in etwa 12 Min. gemacht.
Ich bin ganz nass und habe
nasse Schottenunterhosen an.
Wir haben ein rasantes Tempo drauf.
Aber jetzt spitzt es sich zu,
weil wir uns sehr auf das Ende
dieser langen Wanderung freuen.
Da ist es Burki.
Da: The End
of the West Highland Way.
Ja, nein, nein!
Die Stöcke kannst du haben.
Wegen dieser lausigen Statue!
- Ich brauche sie nicht mehr.
Ich gratuliere dir.
Seit zweieinhalb Wochen trage ich
das Glengoyne-Gebräu mit mir.
Und das gibt es jetzt.
Wir haben eigentlich heute
noch gesagt,
ob wir es körperlich schaffen mit
einem Rucksack, bei diesem Wetter,
154 km quer
durch die Wildnis zu wandern.
Das Erlebnis zählt und einmal
durchhalten, ist immer gesund.
Ich bin glücklich,
ich bin sehr glücklich.
Weisst du,
was wir noch machen könnten?
Wenn das Fläschchen leer ist,
legen wir einen Wunsch hinein,
den wir in den nächsten zehn Jahren
zusammen haben, und werfen ins Meer.
Sehr schön. Das machen wir.
Etwas esoterisch,
aber nicht schlecht.
Das ist nostalgisch, romantisch.
Ist es möglich, dass wir
ohne Rucksäcke ans Meer runtergehen?
Es war etwas absurd: Da wandern wir
150 km durch die Natur
und stehen dann am Ziel
an einer Hauptstrasse.
Ist es gut?
- Ja, ich bin dabei.
Schöne Idee.
Nimm ein Wässerchen!
Ja, so habe ich mir das Ziel
irgendwie nicht vorgestellt.
Der Porsche
war eigentlich das Schönste.
Wir haben etwas gefeiert
und am nächsten Morgen war es Zeit,
um Abschied zu nehmen.
Jonny ging Richtung Flughafen
und ich auf die Fähre.
Ciao!
- Zu Ende ist das Abenteuer.
Komm gut nach Hause.
Es geht noch zwei Tage.
Tschüss!
Geh jetzt rein, verschwinde!
Und plötzlich war alles vorbei.
Was ich auf dieser Reise
gelernt habe:
Es lohnt sich, ab und zu anzuhalten,
innezuhalten, einzuatmen
und den Moment, die Landschaft
oder das Gegenüber zu geniessen.
Diese Erfahrung
nehmen wir nach Hause
und haben weiterhin die Augen offen
für die kleinen, schönen Sachen.
Es war der absolute Hammer, Burki!
Mit dir gehe ich jederzeit
wieder durch dick und dünn!
Dito, mein Freund, jederzeit wieder.